well the trial of former Donald Trump
campaign chairman Paul Manafort
completed its third day today
prosecutors brought out evidence that
Manafort lived a luxurious lifestyle
bought suits they suggested were too
expensive for one man to buy maintained
overseas accounts and then lied about
his income on loan applications this was
all to bolster their case that Paul
Manafort deserves more prison time than
most murderers more than once during the
trial the judge T SLS the 3rd blasted
prosecutors for simply shaming Manafort
without offering any actual evidence of
criminal behavior Jojo Jena VII is a
former US Attorney for the District of
Columbia and he joins us tonight Joe
thanks a lot for coming on I never
thought that I would defend Paul
Manafort who I've always thought was a
little on the sleazy side but I think
it's worth defending the principle of
evenly and fairly applied justice and
it's not a crime to buy expensive suits
and you shouldn't get 300 years in
prison for tax evasion right you're
absolutely right Tucker what you are
watching is what it what is called in
the Justice Department an in terrorem
prosecution the use of Terror legal
tactics to destroy a human being to try
and force him to cooperate when he has
nothing to cooperate with and what the
Special Counsel has done mr. Muller is
he has chosen his Jack the Ripper like
leader Andrew Weissman to use the type
of tactics that are properly reserved
for mafia gangs for terrorists and they
have converted Paul Manafort into this
ugly creature this is one of the most
unfortunate moments in the history of
the of the FBI and the Department of
Justice this this case is the Rosemary's
Baby of Rod Rosenstein who forced this
prosecution permitted the abuse of
tactics which occurred during the
investigation and which are occurring in
this trial agreed to by the FBI director
Chris Rhea and of course the Attorney
General is asleep somnambula as this
horrific embarrassment to the department
continues in the Eastern District of
Virginia
this is a disgusting display of
prosecutorial abuse for which the
Attorney General and his deputy should
be ashamed is there anybody that you
know personally who'd with a straight
face say yeah three hundred and five
years in prison seems like an
appropriate punishment for tax evasion
is there anybody who would say that no
is the answer so how can they charge him
with crime so that sentence is so
clearly disproportionate to the crime
because the Deputy Attorney General mr.
Rosenstein has given mr. Muller full
authority to do whatever he wants and
because the ultimate goal here is to
quote get something on president Trump
they've decided to ruin Paul Manafort
who has no criminal record whatever you
may think of his political leanings and
his tactics over the years or who his
overseas clients work he does not
deserve this the Attorney General knows
that the Deputy Attorney Note general
knows that but you know what they don't
care because they know that Muller wants
to get Trump that's what this is about
there's nothing for Manafort to flip on
for heaven's sakes so what you are
watching is a bizarre mistreatment of a
human being this is a case that you get
one two three years at most
but Muller and Weissman and all the
people in the department just can't give
it up 1.3 years a year and three months
rather that's the average sentence for
tax fraud in this country it's
unbelievable Joe Joe gentlemen thank you
for that perspective this is your world
and we appreciate it